if you're in the United States have
visited the states or haven't even heard
of the states then you've probably heard
a lot of chatter about restricting US
citizenship
soundbite I said we will get the
criminals out the drug lords the gang
members we're getting them out but
debate over who should get to be a
citizen isn't new hey guys I mean Mayan
and this Sunday on aj+ we're talking
about today is immigration debate US
citizenship and who's historically been
excluded spoiler alert it wasn't white
man
[Music]
there are a few ways you can get US
citizenship if one or both of your
parents have it then you most likely
qualify or you can be naturalized if
you're eligible so if you marry a US
citizen or if you've been an immigrant
with permanent resident status for five
years then this would be your path or
you can be born on US soil and that's
called birthright citizenship it doesn't
matter what your parents immigration
status is and not everybody is cool with
that critics say it encourages
undocumented immigrants to come to the
States and give birth here so that their
children can get citizenship we spoke to
pierce bureau a law professor at Temple
University who specializes in
immigration and constitutional law he
dispelled a common myth about the
children of undocumented immigrants an
individual who's born here to
undocumented parents can turn around and
secure legal status for the parents
until the child turns 21 so it's a myth
that so-called anchor baby who's born
here can immediately secure legal status
for his or her parent he says not a
stronger critique of birthright
citizenship is that it encourages birth
tourism you know traveling to the u.s.
specifically to have a baby and then
maybe just staying here for a few days
and the people who do that are paying
the big bucks and in fact they enter the
country legally they're actually
hospitals and sell packages for such
individuals so they take care of
information but he says the numbers are
relatively small maybe in the tens of
thousands compared with the estimated
hundreds of thousands of children born
to undocumented immigrants the real
debate centers on them this isn't really
new though disagreements over who gets
to be a US citizen are almost as old as
the nation itself in the early 18th
century you had to have lived in the US
for two years and be of good moral
character before you could become a
citizen but that only applied to three
white persons if you weren't white you
couldn't become a citizen since then
winning citizenship rights for people of
color has been an uphill struggle the
infamous Dred Scott decision aka the
Supreme Court's
worst decision ever played a big role in
the black fight for recognition so
here's the back story Scott was born
into slavery in Virginia his owner took
him to Illinois and the Wisconsin
territory which were both free states
Scott tried to buy his freedom after his
owner died but they would let him so he
took legal action in 1857 he took his
case to the Supreme Court the court
decided that because he was black he was
not a citizen and therefore had no
standing to sue in federal court it also
confirmed a principle that slaves were
property not people and that decision
stood until after the Civil War when the
Reconstruction era introduced the 14th
amendment the amendment says anyone born
on US soil is a citizen this was the
first time citizenship as a birthright
was officially enshrined into the
Constitution and that meant the recently
freed slaves got citizenship but the
struggle for citizenship for people of
color didn't end there the Chinese
Exclusion Act closed our borders to
Chinese laborers and if they were
already settled in America it made them
permanent aliens by excluding them from
citizenship but the Supreme Court
decision United States versus Wong Kim
Ark changed all that it upheld the 14th
amendment deciding that the exclusion
act couldn't overrule the citizenship of
people born in the US since the ruling
anyone born in the u.s. to foreign
parents has to be given you a
citizenship regardless of their parents
nationality or immigration status but
it's the country's first resident who'd
be the last to be granted birthright
citizenship on a federal level obviously
I'm talking about Native Americans they
were the last to get this right when
President Calvin Coolidge finally signed
the Indian citizenship and nationality
act in 1924 that was nearly 60 years
after the 14th amendments ratification
we talked a lot about race restrictions
on birthright citizenship but what about
when it comes to restrictions on
naturalization that finally became
illegal in 1952 when Congress passed the
Immigration and Nationality Act since
then the laws regarding citizenship and
Naturalization have remained largely
unchanged but it's not like legislators
haven't tried Congress has introduced
legislation to scale back birth right in
every session for the last 20 years
both Republicans and Democrats have
introduced a number of bills intended to
restrict children of undocumented
immigrants born in the u.s. from
becoming citizens in fact even Trump's
administration includes skeptics a
birthright citizenship but don't get
ahead of yourselves these proposals
haven't made much headway and professor
Spiro doesn't think they will anytime
soon it pretty clearly requires an
amendment to the Constitution of the
United States the probability of the
administration being able to secure the
supermajority approval that's required
for constitutional amendments virtually
no birthright is here to stay and
race-based restrictions on who can
naturalize are gone so we're good right
everybody's happy
not exactly policymakers still restrict
who can and can't become a citizen they
just do it using immigration laws if you
can't get permanent residency status and
makes it a lot harder to naturalize and
become a citizen take them documented
immigrants for example they're an
estimated 11 million of them living in
the US with half of them coming from
Mexico and 78 percent of them have lived
here in the US for 10 years or longer a
lot of undocumented immigrants moved
here as children over a million and
despite working paying taxes and
starting families here they have no path
to citizenship remember if you're a
permanent resident you can apply to
naturalize after just five years during
former President Obama's campaign he
promised to pass the DREAM Act which
would have created a path to citizenship
for undocumented immigrants who arrived
here before the age of 16 but he faced
hard opposition in Congress the DREAM
Act never passed so what's the chance
immigration reform could happen under
Trump he's used friendlier language
towards the dreamers recently but
anti-immigration constituencies are big
Trump supporters can he really afford to
alienate them and if there's no
immigration reform what does that mean
for the future of undocumented
immigrants in this country birthright
citizenship is actually pretty uncommon
across the globe in fact only 33 nations
have it why do you think that is let us
know in the comments and don't forget to
like share and subscribe